αν είχε να σχολιάσει κάτι αλλά δεν νομίζω να δεν είχε ποτέ έτσι πως άλλους
ανθρώπους κατακάκιακα ήταν ένα κατακακία ήναι να θεωρί τους άλλους υπεύθυνους α το τοτιείχε συότι
ια τ ότι είχε σύμβει τι θυμάστε από τις τελευταίες μέρες πρινθύγιτα σπάδοκει είνες ημέρεστε
αν πολύ δυσ άχεστες γιότι ήτανε στο νοσοκομείο και πως τις τελευταίες τον τηλευταίο εν
καιρό δυστυχώς δεν είχε επαφει με το εριβάλλον και πομένος δεν ήταν καθόλου ήταν πολύ
δύσκολο και φεύγει αλλά η οικογένεια δεν είρεμε ναι γίνεται κάτι που συγκνώνισε όλη την
κύπρο ησήληση το τάφο πωςστο αντιμετωπις αμέσις και αβάδοπου νήταν ττθυμάστε όταν χτύπησε το τηλέφωνο
σας και θα σενημέρωσαν ότι ασιθεοκουνιάδοσμου ίμου σπίτι και ιχθοκουνιάζουμ να μου το ποί ότι
αυτό και αυτό ήταν λίες μέρες πριν που θα να κάμουμε τον νημόσινο ν κάτι
πγοστο γαν μπορών το καταλάβω στορα δεν το χογάνι το μιαλόμου και δεν μπορο νδεν
καταλάδεν εκατάλαβα ποτέμο γιατί αγίνει αυτό το πράμα και δυστυχώσει ελεχθεήκαν και διάφορα κβλακίες πό
να πωότιγύρεύαν αν ήταν θαμένος μέσα στη τράκα ήταν πουμελία πράματα που ήταν γελία τον
γεκείνο αλλά ως το ρα δεν πογρά καταλβω γιατί εκάμαν αυτό το πράμα ζητήσατσεις να
δείτε αυτούς ου ήταν πίσω από αυτό το θελεοόχι όχι ε συγχωρέςαμε δεδεν ασχολήθηκα βασικά
καθόλουμε το πλέομεκείνους εξερεται ότι του τον ίβραμε γιατί εο ένας από τους ένας αγάτης